radha ministro vodka dosia ha dejado the
Council of Ministers smoothly achieved
an agreement on the long-awaited
directive on the protection of workers
from the risks related to exposure to
carcinogens or mutagens at work today's
agreement is an important step in
further progress in the area of
protecting workers ojas prasanna orbital
dealt with the issues of unemployment
especially the unemployment of the young
and youth guarantee therefore we also
welcome the decision by the Commission
to continue in this initiative including
the increase of its financial framework
I could not be happier that the council
has agreed to the Commission's proposal
we launched this proposal because cancer
kills more workers than any other
occupational disease and it brings
enormous suffering of course for the
people themselves the workers themselves
but also for their families we need
indeed working standards also in
fisheries this industry is the fourth
largest in the world and provides jobs
for more than 100,000 people in Europe
this legislation ladies and gentlemen
transposes an agreement that was reached
by the sectoral social partners it's a
proof of the quality of the social
dialogue at European level and it is
proof that we can fully use the
legislative power to mate to make
agreements binding throughout the
European Union so that the health and
safety of all fishermen is equally
protected